i'm gonna go through some of these
questions here real quick
so bear with me here
so again i put it the link in the chat
so
okay marshall
the power bars
yeah marshall um
you know i know you got like two
different emails for some reason in the
past uh one isabel that was not updated
but i'll get you the your power bar
thing downloads again
one i won uh two questions show enrico
or uni rico
uh
i don't have uni wrinkle honestly i
don't know if it's gonna work with a
wrinkle chart
um
personally i i've got i know some people
that use wrinkle charts
i don't even know what the settings
would be you know if what you'd set it
at anymore is two or what you know it
really seems that the old ninjatrader
seven and ninjatrader eight it almost
seems that their wrinkle calculations
are different i don't know
um
well let's see i don't know i think i'm
not sure how it's going to look i've
never looked at it on a wrinkle chart
but let's uh pull it up here and i don't
i don't have a uni ranco chart
well you can't use two
that's for sure because i see what it's
doing it's
two
two price levels that's not going to be
enough the the way the program is it's
uh it needs more
data
than two price levels in a bar so let's
see if i make it higher so if you're
using something like say you're using a
three you know a two range target i know
people that used to range charts
it's not going to work so let's see here
let's just open it up here a bit
you know i don't
know let's go back here
you can sort of take it through some of
this stuff
[Music]
what is this this is why i am yeah um
yeah it's
honestly these way this wrinkle chart
looks it looks a bit like a like a range
based chart
i i don't know what settings you use on
your wrinkle chart
um can it be read in bloodhound no i
don't not think it can and someone
emailed me
saying that it cannot i don't use
wrinkle bars i don't use renko i don't
use blood hump
yeah brian was asking no brian left but
um
he was asking about the setting
in
let's go back to a minute-based chart
this trade parameters because he's
asking if
if you use three in here if i trade
validity and bars we'll set to 3 or
trade entry and ticks was set to 3.
so if you had trade entry set to 3
validity in bars it would have to move
in that direction within 3 bars
before it prints a signal now
the thing to note
okay when you're using trade entry
signal is
let's open this up a bit here
once it prints it won't reprint okay but
if you're not using a trade entry signal
right so let's just
disable it here
if you're not using this
it can reprint because conditions can be
met in a bar
but then they can disappear right
especially if you you know you're using
a minute based chart right the first
40 seconds of the bar is negative right
it's all bearish order flow so it's
printing like oh it looks like it's a
cell and oftentimes people get excited
all you know i can get in early the
bar's not closed down you get in 15
seconds early before everybody else that
looks at a one-minute chart you really
got to wait
right
because
it can change it can change on you in
that bar before the bar closes and
that's not a trade that you want to be
taking all right so if the conditions
are going back and forth you'll see the
signal up here disappear but once the
bar closes and it's there it won't
repaint
now if you're using the trade entry
signal
okay
all right two and two
once it prints right it's printing here
okay
it will not print not remove not repaint
so
nothing's going to change right so once
it prints like for example this bar here
right you got this is your
blue bar it's telling you that the the
order flow is bullish right so it's it's
gone up but you notice the bar comes
down
right it didn't disappear because as
soon as that condition is met of within
the next two bars this is the next bar
it moves two ticks from the high of the
signal bar so the highest here is 54
55 56. once it trades 56 it prints the
buy signal here and that's it it will
not disappear will not repaint
it will appear there
can it be used with thinkorswim no it
runs on ninjatrader but
you know i have customers that have my
indicators
they run it on ninjatrader they just get
ninjatrader get a data feed
and you know because they use think or
swim and they use some of the these
other platforms trade of eight because
you know they've got you know ninja
traders really you know even the ninja
trader brokerage now
the new one they just set up their own
clearing membership
is for futures right and i know people
also like to trade stocks and even you
know crypto and stuff and ninjatrader
is really for futures trader but
if you execute on another platform i
have customers that use
my indicators and my indicators run on
the free version of ninjatrader
it's just you know if if
you want to trade futures uh really it
behooves you to get open an account at
ninjatrader i'm not trying to shill for
them
um
lord knows i've got my issues with
ninjatrader but um you know the company
um you know they
sort of
but anyway uh
you could run it on the free version
and as long as you got a data feed you
know you could execute on any front end
you want um you know which is how
you know i have a lot of customers
especially in overseas markets
that you know ninja trader brokerage
only basically allows um
you know the main exchanges but you know
i got people trading in malaysia japan
and
they can't access those markets through
a ninja trader so they just execute on
their front end of you know wherever
their broker is in those markets
and they just use the
ninjatrader platform for charting
with a buy sell signal show only once
the bar is completed okay i sort of
covered that al hopefully um
again it will
if you're using the trade entry signal
once the buy or sell signal appears
it will not change but if you're not
using it and the bar is still forming
since the bar is still forming
conditions can change so
it may not be
bullish anymore so when it was initially
bullish
then it changes no longer bullish
it's
gonna
un-print so it'll paint
the but the conditions change it'll go
away but once the bar is closed once
that you know if you're using a
one-minute chart once that one minute is
over and there's a buy signal or sell
signal it will stay there it's not going
to change
can you ask what's the blue and the
the blue and the dark red those are the
the
bars that
have the flow edge conditions met now
you could change it right so you don't
like
using blue and dark red especially if
you're using a black background chart
right dark red might be hard to see you
could change the colors
all right you just go in there and say
oh you know dark red is too hard to see
you know maybe you want either a lighter
red or you know you want even you know
you could use magenta all right
i use magenta for some things but if
you're on a black background chart using
dark red is going to be a lot harder to
see
i know i know some people that like to
use yellow on a black background drop me
i like white background charts
but you can only have
you know so many different colors going
on at once but you can change those
colors right so dark blue
right here or just blue rather and
change you could change it to whatever
you want right
you want powder blue light blue cyan
um it really depends on on your your
tastes on the colors
um yeah friends ask you know can throw
power bars on here too
sure
uh power bar
again i'll just keep this
strength low what do i got on here
whoops powerpoint flow edges i got the
three so
just set them both at the basic level
just so you can sort of see they they
oh i think i got power bars as
magenta also
power bars are the cyan color power bars
are the magenta as well um
actually
you know
sorry to see how again this is a one
minute chart and you sort of see the
trends going on here blue blue blues
magenta magenta magenta blue blue blue
magenta magenta magenta
you know even on this trend down you got
one blue but no signal you've just seen
the magenta triangle magenta triangles
all the way down
blue blue blue
you know down down down
up up up you know honestly if i made
them the same color
so what i got i got blue and magenta for
flow edge
cyan and magenta if i changed it to well
just go to cyan and magenta for both of
them
sort of bring it in here you know it's
nice trends down nice trends up
but you know that's both of them with
the same color yeah you can you know
just sort of show you the differences in
here
um change the colors back to uh
what did i have here
blue okay where's blue
i'll go blue and red
red's down at the bottom
not red
what color can i use
i use
indigo
as you can see here
dark blue right
the magenta this is a dark red
dark red dark red so you can see it
they're they're not signaling on the
same bars
they i don't want to say they complement
each other but
they're coming in here right
you you're able to catch you know using
both of them you're able to sort of be
in
sync with the markets
up and down up and you know on the moves
up
on the moves down right because here
you're seeing you know some of it's
driven by power bars right on the way up
here this
then on the way down you can see these
indigo purple bars sell signal so you
don't see any buys coming in here sell
sell sell sell sell
sell buy then sell again sell sell sell
back down
but anyway let me
take it off here
get a couple more questions
let's see back up there
all right um
yeah did that
okay bob
um yeah bobby i saw your email yesterday
having a chance to get reply to you
i'll do that it's it's i haven't tried
it yet with uh markers
because the try to entry signal or
i mean it works on my real time data
um
so i'm not sure you know if you're
running it on playback how it works i
said i run it and we've tested it
for quite a while for months in real
time data um not on on playback see how
we find that sometimes with running it
on playback
there's always you know some
problems that come up with the playback
data
but bob i'm going to
reply to your email uh this evening
i said i just didn't have a chance
yesterday it's just
really caught up on a lot of stuff can
you the gain and stop philosophy auto
programmed in
um no frank
you you can use atms
right
uh
you know from when you get into a trade
you know if you use the
chart trader right you could set your
things up in here
if i got anything set up in
here you know i've got different atms
here for different markets that i use
um you know so you get into a trade
it'll just automatically enter your your
profit and take loss and again
everyone's got different profit and take
loss levels
the overnight session doesn't require
more margin if you're going to hold it
overnight you know basically if you're
going to go into a close and hold a
position overnight then yeah it requires
margin
and you know again i don't advocate
people
i i know people that sort of get around
it by closing out the position
um you know
before the market closes and then just
reinitiating it overnight but again you
know that's
not really the the way the market is
intended to work um but if trading
overnights
it's
i still pay the same you know the same
margin i know some brokers they they
you know and there's times you know when
the markets are extremely volatile you
know during covid right
they would overnight
session
or even during the trump when trump
would go crazy and tweet stuff
overnight
they would have they would revert back
to normal um
daily margin and it wasn't until
the markets reopened during the day that
they would revert back to their intraday
margin
um i'll ask the review
all the differences between all of them
you know what i i have that on my
whiteboard to make a video of the
differences between every indicator that
we have because you know honestly
there's so many different ways
to analyze the market especially with
order flow you know people think that
you know for example
market profile right you have a
you have a profile on your chart
right or you know you're following
market everyone thinks there's only one
way to look at it no there's so many
different ways right there's many
different setups just on a volume
profile or even a market profile and
especially with order flow when you
start digging into the footprint chart
um
you know there's so many different ways
to analyze it because there's now a
sudden
there's so many different pieces of data
for you to
to analyze right to look at right you
got delta you got point of control you
got imbalances
and then you got the combinations of you
know well how about delta with you know
certain types of imbalances
or um
you know just even price direction you
know price action of a bar
with
uh imbalances you know how does that
affect there's a lot of different ways
to do it but you know again i'm
probably
you know i've never i don't like to run
these you know black friday sales or you
know christmas sales things like that
um
yeah but some people have been asking me
oh you know a package deal for this
package deal for that um probably this
indicator the flow edges is not but some
of our previous ones i got indicators
like on absorption um trap traders et
cetera that a pipeline to get be putting
together some black friday specials for
for those
but um yeah
doing you know a video of all the
differences that's that's on my
whiteboard to get to but you know that's
gonna be a long presentation
richard s do i use this with any other
indicator no i use it by itself is there
any correlation with volume spikes well
this takes into account volume
anyway so it doesn't take into account
volume spikes anyway you know generally
the market is going to move in the
direction of volume at least it should
because when there's volume in the
market you know there's there's people
transacting and you know the market
generally moves towards
the volume you know volume
volume in a sense the word when you
think of the word volume
um
there's different types of volume okay i
mean there's volume that's coming in
during a move which helps propel the
move there's volume market can go up
towards volume and react off that right
because now you have a resistance level
or
volume could appear you know resting
liquidity is volume
um
as well so
it's
the sort of different ways to use volume
and flow edges uses volume in it
one asks
which
chart settings work better
low edges indicator width
well again it it's kind of an open-ended
question it's kind of it's a difficult
question to answer because
like i said everybody
nobody trades the same charts right i
could say i could show you charts right
that it looks great on but not everyone
is going to trade that market or that
chart type
right i showed you wheat wheat's a great
market it's a nice market there's a
couple other grains that i like to look
at but i know nobody else is really
interested in them and it's like
you know i i could show you but honestly
there's going to be very few people that
that like to look at it so i mean you
know these main markets like ym is
giving you some nice trades i mean
bearish here boom boom boom but again
okay fine let's take a look at uh
nobody's interested in
soybean meal right or or wheat or bean
oil
um you know but but they they offer
great opportunities for for traders
you know there's nothing glamorous to
say i trade you know yeah i trade the s
p's everybody knows what an s p is so
even if it's somebody that's not
involved in the markets oh yeah i know
what s p is they turn on the tvs osmp is
up or down they say i trade soy meal i
think you're
you know wacko um
you know 343.20 is a nice little cell
here
you know all the way down into this
324 20. you know you don't think that's
much but this is 100 move right here
on one contract and it's five minutes
ten minutes
right even here right it's another move
it's another move up right there's a lot
of these
lesser glamorous markets you know are
great for trading and that's on a
one-minute chart you know again
i think you could even trade it on a
tick chart because it doesn't
have that volatility that some of these
other markets have i mean look at this
take this one trade here
just late in the day
boom you know
but you get a lot of these moves like
that on you know these markets that not
a lot of people are
interested in trading these markets but
sometimes these other markets trade
order flow really well
okay one thing to note about
flow edges it doesn't use tick replay
okay
so like when you're opening up your
chart
you know
you don't have to have this enabled in
fact it won't work if you have this tick
replay enabled now
that said this is why i don't show it to
you on a footprint chart because my
footprint chart my overflows trader
chart uses tick replay some of my other
indicators use tick replay this one
doesn't so you can't
have
an indicator that does not use tick
replay running with an indicator that
does run tick replay
that's just one of the constraints of
ninjatrader
so that's why you don't see it on on my
footprint chart
um
dave i see your request
okay if you use it with
oh you got your renko chart off the
ninjatrader
forum
okay
yeah he has up that you know nature
trader and then their ecosystem they've
got like free indicators as well i know
a lot of people like to create wrinkle
versions of
renko charts
um i haven't really looked
deeply you know there was a while years
ago i got into renko but i just
it was
difficult to really test anything on on
a wrinkle chart at least for me that's
why i sort of moved back to uh normal
charts you know time based charts volume
based charts
big base charts
okay brian asks
he wants to see on a
nq 20 range chart i've got 20 range here
and nq
okay so here's their
let me close this side down here
it's a 20 range chart
turn the trader off
now again this is with the base settings
of
one so 20 range chart
i don't know if you can see these
signals
in here honestly if i was using a
20 range chart
i wouldn't use a base setting of one
i'd probably go higher
first stop would be
three or four but i'll try it with three
then the next stop i would do is
do the swing strength
and use
a minimum of one
you could really well
you should really probably use something
like five because with the range based
charts lots of times you're going to get
you know it just sort of tick up and
down so you just clean it up a little
bit you know you got your buy here sell
here
a little
cell and buy back and forth here
but again it's
really hard here's a cell on this move
down another couple more cells here so
buying a cell right in here
um you know
even if you eject it all the way up to
five
as far as strength goes
kind of curious
just calculating here so not a lot of
signals
five
don't even see anything earlier there
there was one cell in here
so three is probably a good starting
point
you know there's
it came with the cell here then a buy
right here now
if you
you know wanted to use one
and then
you know try this
swing strength of something
called nine
because you know a lot of times with
range based charts
you know every bar that forms is a
breakout of the previous bar so
you tend to get
you know sort of these up you know these
upticks and then it sells off right
so you can see here
let me just go back well
stick to the day session
eight o'clock where are we here 8 30.
stopped out here stopped out here
stopped out here
stopped out here stopped out here small
winner
then you catch the move down
you know it's about a 40 point move from
the 90s down into the 50s
you know then you get a move here you
know the thing with nasdaq you know i
know a lot of guys that trade nasdaq um
that post on twitter and
honestly as i see their
their results and it's like
loss loss loss lost i've seen them have
nine ten losses in a row but they're
good they keep their losses small
because
they're just looking for this one trade
here
from 46
you know up to 96 you know 50 point move
that covers the previous 10 losses and
usually they're gonna
once it starts going in their favor
they're adding on and stuff
again the nasdaq is
it's not for everybody
but you know nasdaq is sort of a
different creature in the sense that
you're gonna you have to be willing to
take a lot of small losses over and over
yeah dave it does look like it
complements power bars um steve
now i use it actually i do use it on
he's asked steve asked do you ever use
the indicator with two different time
frames or would you get the same signals
on most well generally speaking
you know if you're looking at a 30
second because i use it with 30 second
charts i use it with one minute and i
have them both open
obviously the market is moving in the
same direction
and
i i don't know i just find for me
because there's some markets that i
trade at night in asia asian markets
that
you know during the us day session you
got a lot of different markets you could
be looking at and trading you know you
got
you know i know people that watch like
four or five different markets crude oil
s ps um
ultra bonds
uh russell ym even though some of those
are correlated
and i'm like well
i sort you know at night there's only
one or two markers i'm interested in
trading but i could trade it off a
30 second chart i changed it off i
traded off a range based chart i traded
off um
[Music]
you know a one minute chart sometimes i
see things like i may see something on a
30 second chart that just never develops
on a one minute chart
right and just as i might see it on a 25
range chart it doesn't appear on it on a
time based chart so
it gives me you know other views into
the market on something that i could
take advantage of
um
darren asks
is it created by imbalance levels no
it's not
created by imbalances
you know i love
seeing imbalances in the markets and i
use imbalances in my trading
but these are not based off of
imbalances in the market in the sense of
in the footprint chart
okay i mean i talk about balance right
market wants to move away from balance
to find a new balance area that's what
the market does
right market rallied up here found some
balance sold off bomb balance down here
rally back up found balance here sold
off again right that's the markets do
they
always searching for balance but you
know the way the markets move is
everyone's got a different idea of where
the market should be trading
um yeah peter
okay guys i'm gonna
go peter i'll send you
something here my
personal email um if you want you send
me something there dave
yeah two contracts this way i trade two
contracts 20 tick target
three trades and done for the day really
that's
great
that's great advice i mean that's what i
tell people people sometimes they think
it's
trading has got to be a marathon and
sometimes it feels like a marathon right
you got to trade all day to maximize no
have your target for the day have a nut
so to speak
and go for it once you reach it
turn off the machines
you know that's
that goes for winning and losing too
right it's hard for people especially if
they're they're losing
you know
their target for the day may be 500 they
could reach it they're fine to turn off
the computer go do other stuff but
they're down 500. next thing they
instead of turning off the computer and
walking away they do the opposite they
keep trading next thing they're down a
thousand um
you know to me that that's really the
ability that
that
differentiates
successful traders from unsuccessful
traders is
taking the winnings put in your pocket
and going home
you know and it's hard for people
because sometimes people get greedy
and you know it's interesting because
everyone says well you know the markets
are run by algos you know the computers
are taking over
they are
they they do provide
liquidity in the market etc but at the
same time
the computers aren't you know they don't
know greed
they don't know fear
you know but individual traders you know
the ones that got to pull the trigger
are subjected to that so you know
markets do have
do sense fear and greed based on traders
right and if everything is so
computerized nowadays then
you wouldn't have that factor
if
you understand what i'm what i'm saying
but yeah dave that's um
that's exactly what you should be doing
antonius asks uh
okay yeah roy uh
he's asking about rty
yesterday
uh where's my rty
russell
um
about the drop
using okay so why can you please show
flow edges in rty during the drop right
after the open on tuesday um
tuesday tuesday yeah the dates
whoops
show date range here
make sure i get the right date here
um
what was tuesday
should i get the right date
sorry
calendar uh tuesday was the night
okay so let's
do
i think i got this set at a high level
one and nine so
zero
the base settings one and um
i didn't capture anything on that move
down
this morning we move up
yeah i wish i could say yeah yeah it
would caught this whole move down you
know sometimes no there's nothing in the
overflow that's really stand outish
in terms in this case in terms of the
flow edge but today
this morning
right off the open
it was there right it was
this was 840.
you know you had a sell signal here that
uh what was that
on the 2394 area then it hit this low
here
very bullish
flow came in right and then it rallied
straight up
nice big green bars all the way up right
you get a little bit of a pullback here
i mean there's a small red bar here um
another red bar here but
it's just
stretching its legs here
um this was today yesterday
sure i can't remember what the move was
yesterday
yeah yesterday
not much the signal came before the cash
open yeah
with anything when you're reading order
flow be careful you know that the 15
minutes leading up to the cash open
um
because obviously once the cash open
things are going to gyrate a bit more
and you got a lot of uh
volume coming in
but there was nothing on on that tuesday
morning on the one minute chart
but this morning
on the rally there was
bob asked about the triangle yeah you
know i've
i've asked the programmer to to do that
like
even on the power bars i asked him like
five times and then this one i said yeah
i need the setting to make it bigger and
he never does it for me oh
it's
i find it too small personally um
and i've asked him multiple times to
enlarge it i'll have to chase him up
again um
and do it
i don't know why he doesn't do it for me
but uh
yeah
it would be nice to be able to have that
function to make it a little bit larger
at least you know have a setting in
there we could adjust the pixel
size don't know
what that was maybe that
you know that does is just move it down
lower or higher
i i don't
understand why he didn't maybe didn't
understand my
way i described it to make the triangle
bigger
but um
anyway guys i i thanks for i'm going to
end it there i mean we went about an
hour and 40 minutes um it's a bit long
but um i hope i got through all your
questions dave
and uh
yeah dave i'll get your other license
sorted out
and
it was at the beginning uh
marshall
i'll resend you out the
the link again for the power bars from
earlier
um i'll have to check which email it
went to because i know for some reason
i've got an older email there's like uh
saskatel or something like that um
for some reason in my database but
anyway guys have a great uh day and
again you know if you're interested just
go to flow edges actually i've showed
you the
page here um you know to get it so it
there's a video on here
again about tick charts right here it's
22 minutes long there is a uh you know
we also have a
there's a very
in my opinion thorough user guide you
know i i
sometimes you know like i said you know
there's software out there that looks
interesting to me as a user right i'm
always interested in learning new ways
to trade and you know things that i can
incorporate but sometimes you know the
way the the documentation is is pants
it's lousy
so i try to be thorough
in
documentation and explaining the
settings how everything works so you
understand that
so again thanks for your time everybody
have a great rest of the week
and
go to flowedges.com to take advantage of
this deal again next week it's going to
go back up to uh well not back up to it
hasn't been there i just released this
but it's going to go to its regular
price 497
next week so again take advantage of
this early bird price
so thanks everyone have a great day
bye
you